hey leute ich bin es wieder eure wann
she also ich wollte nur sagen dass es
bald wieder mehr videos gibt von mir von
meinen freunden und von meinem schatz
sie weil ich seit kurzem vergeben bin
und ich wollte ich noch was sagen ich
bin stolz adobe fan und nur wenn ihr
meint also die die hasser ihr könnt uns
da gebiet fans fertig machen
das packt ihr eh nicht also hat doch
lieber auf sei doch eh nur neidisch auf
dgb und wenn ihr meint ihr könnt uns
fertig machen dann machen wir euch mal
richtig fertig also haltet lieber eure
maul und macht nicht immer so guck mal
wie doof die ist und die ist doch schwul
sie ist nicht schwul und wenn er sagt
dass sie schwul ist seit ihr selber
schwul oder was auch immer
mir ist das scheißegal aber lasst
einfach dagegen ruhe und lässt vor allem
die defense in ruhe denn es reicht dass
sie meint ihr könntet jedes mal da gb
fertig machen und vor allem die defense
lief daniela
[Musik]
juni ist my friend liefern